well what a day of chess it was magnus
carson's non-defeated streak has come to
an
end it's taken 125 games
and the dude abides duda from poland has
taken him down
it was a brilliant game the last time
magnus lost was on july the 31st
2018 and it took quite
special play from duda to achieve it so
let's go into the action
and duda had the white pieces magnus
carlsen with black
goes for the karakan the thing i like
about magnus's play
even though he's got this undefeated
streak he picks a very
risky line knight to f6
and this is a very dynamic line the last
time magnus played this was against
peter svidler in 2018 and apparently he
said
after the game to david howe that he was
never going to play this move again
here he is here he is with another loss
probably won't be doing it again
and the point of this move is that after
the capture on f6
black takes with the e pawn getting this
unbalanced pawn structure
when the black king castles king side
it's got an extra pawn
defending it the downside of this is
that
white has this majority of pawns over
here on the queen side
which later on can be very strong
especially as white has an easy way to
get a past pawn so structurally
speaking bad but maybe piecewise okay
for magnus
now the game continued with theoretical
moves they both
developed in a standard fashion both
sides trying to get their kings safe and
black gets castle quickly and now
after queen c2 the main move check and
then
h5 this is an important move in this
variation
black uses this pawn often to cause some
problems if white castles this way
and removes it from harm's way white
simply develops with bishop e3 and now
black plays knight d7 trying to get
those pieces into the game
white goes queen side it's actually
quite risky for white's castle king side
in this position because later on
black can get quite an initiative with
the black knight coming around
towards the king and also this queen
coming on this diagonal so queen side
castling leads to this very unique
and dynamic position here now magnus
plays move that's only been tried
once or twice before mainly by the young
dutch talent jordan van furiste and that
was the aggressive move
b5 and this just shows that magnus is in
the mood
for some action they do say fortune
favors the brave
maybe that didn't happen here well i
know i've given the result away but
i think it had to be given away in this
game i know you're going to complain
about that but come on it's big news
i've got to tell you
and this move b5 just shows that spirit
of going for it
it might not work in the like short term
but in the long term
surely fortune favors the brave and
magnus has shown this
throughout his last couple of years in
chess
the other move here would have been
knight to f8 a much more solid approach
but
b5 it is and now to dude's credit
he goes for the most ambitious move d5
this practically forces magnus to play
c5
sacrificing the pawn on b5 now i would
never
consider capturing this pawn myself
because
after bishop takes b5 you open up a line
towards your king
but this shows the development of modern
chess in modern
modern era we could say people are much
braver and they rely
on their defensive capabilities to a
much higher degree
this is because most players use
computers
to analyze with computers show better
ways to defend and
modern players are learning how to grab
that dangerous pawn the poison pawn
and then hang tough defend you know what
saran would say grab that pawn
magnus now plays rook to b8 that line
is now for the rook another interesting
idea i was thinking about here
afterwards was
maybe you could force that bishop to a4
and try a move
such as rook e5 the idea of this is to
get the rook
off that diagonal so you can try to play
knight b6 next move
this could be something to investigate
in the future but rook b8 seems very
natural
and now c4 might as well cement that
bishop
and here magnus plays a6 a very logical
move
it's very interesting to see that
ex-world champion kramnik
bit of the legend all round suggested
rook takes e3 here
giving up more material and this is a
very anti-computer move the computers
hate this move
but kramnik's idea is that after pawn
takes
the black knight cements itself here and
white doesn't have moves like
f4 to get rid of that knight this is a
very interesting way to play the
computers really don't like it
but i like what kramnik's saying here
it's
great chances to start an attack
somewhere on the queen side so a very
interesting possibility magnus plays a6
and now the bishop retreats to a4 and he
gow plays
rook e7 this has a similar idea to what
we've seen before
the knight wants to centralize the rook
wants to come over here
white plays a good move knight to g3
also thinking about attacking
and bringing that knight to one of these
attractive light squares
black continuous plan knight to e5
and now knight to e4 a very human move
in actual fact
a better move here would have been the
pre-emptive
bishop d2 the idea of this move is to
stop
the maneuver that we see in a minute the
rook coming around to b4
the bishop later on will also be quite
comfortable on this diagonal
in the game knight to e4 allowed rook to
b7
duda had a long think here but he can't
really allow
rook takes b2 ideas and he has to play
b3
i think the reason he had a long
thinkers because he was working out
the complexities that were going to
occur after the following exchange sack
and this is full steam ahead magnus now
he really wanted to win this game
just showing that risk factor was very
brave but again
duda has to have all the credit for
keeping him at arms bay
the dude was in good form last time he
defeated magnus carson the prime
minister
of poland actually rung him up and
congratulated him so
i wonder if he's going to get that phone
call again tonight i'm sure he deserves
it it's great to see
these prime ministers and people showing
so much interest in the game
can you imagine that in america trump
giving you a little call after you beat
magnus
hey donald yeah yeah okay yeah don't
breathe on me yep it's okay
okay but anyway on to the game rook to
b4
and magnus keeps throwing those pieces
into the position
rook takes a4 and again to the human eye
this looks incredibly
dangerous for white because now the rook
is lined up
it's a pity this pawn on c5 is in the
way because otherwise bishop to a3 would
be
a stunningly dangerous move but magnus
continues developing he can't get his
queen in the attack if that queen could
get in the attack it'd be great but
queen b6
doesn't really achieve anything here
it's not coming in it has
no entrance points in the position and
remember
what white has to do here is just
survive try to make some exchanges and
win
the ending bishop to f5 that piece comes
in and now after rookie one i would say
the losing move h4
this is just far too slow here it's rare
to see magnus go wrong but he
needed to play with a little bit more
urgency in the position
and the defensive play from white here
is simply simply astonishing
knight g4 would have been a much better
move trying to
create complications and entering
straight into tactics
the point of this move is that after
something like f3
magnus could have captured the knight
and now play a move such
bishop e5 the rook now wants to come
into b2
and after let's say bishop to c3 here
which
i think must be the normal move the
bishop
moves into d4 and even this queen can
now
sneak into e5 and black has more inroads
into white's position here so h4
was far too slow and now h3 stops any of
these shenanigans
with that knight darting into the
position the knight therefore
tries to find another route in but now
another great move
the rook comes centralized allowing the
other rook to come in
and in some cases it can make exchanges
when your material up
you want to exchange pieces off the
board magnus throws the knight in
and now g4 forcing the bishop back
and again this next move real real class
king to d1 i mean seriously how many
players would think of this move just
trying to get the king
away from a potentially dangerous place
on the queen side
it's a weird little maneuver and even
though the king still looks
like it's under a lot of frets here
there's no obvious way that black can
increase the pressure that's
magnus's problem here he plays a very
human move
f5 trying to break open the position but
now white makes some more exchanges
and he simply takes on f5 again both
players showing no fear here
you give me a poor magnus um i will take
it
i am the polish pac-man i'm gonna
munch my way through your pawns and
pieces boy you may be world champion
but i'm going to eat them all magnus
idea he gets a check
but again duder blocks that with f3
black queen now comes to a potentially
dangerous diagonal
but it's blocked again bishop c3 and we
can see here that white's
starting to get quite a harmonious
position
and even some counter-attacking chances
with this strong piece
black's only try is to try to get the
queen into the position
via the g file but now queen e4
centralizing
queen to g2 and rook e1 again
very nice centralization of the pieces
here
even here as white i'd be scared after
magnus's move queen takes a2 i'll be
like oh come on man give us a break
he's threatening such ideas a rook b1
but the way to get through these kind of
positions you just have to calculate
and show no fear try to exchange try to
swap off
and there's only one move here but it's
a good one queen c2
offering the exchange of queens and now
the king can come to d2
because we're blocking that force field
from the queen
queen takes c4 rook to e8
check this force is off well more pieces
i mean the other options here were just
as bad magnus's idea here
is to try to complicate things by at
least giving himself a check on d5
when the chips are down and you're
struggling you might as well throw
everything into the pot
there's there's no point you know fading
away you might as well
burn in a blaze of glory and i think
that's what magnus
is aiming to do here but white has so
many pieces now
as we can see his material up and
as long as he holds his nerve here which
he does very well
he can get to the victory line and there
may have been
easier ways for white to have won this
but it's always nice having two extra
rooks
magnus fights on and now
in this position duda takes quite a
practical choice
the best thing to do is when you're
winning you know simplification is good
but if you see an opportunity to attack
you have to calculate it
and in this position queen d8 would have
actually been
not the move that behaved but a much
better idea giving up your rook
but forcing the black king out into the
open
and we can see after a series of checks
that the black king is in hopeless
situation this kind of sequence will end
with the black queen
being lost so duder gives magnus a glimp
glimpse of hope there with rook f8 but
again
after king c1 magnus has no checks
and there's really no way in white's
pieces are stopping
everything so the game goes on but
eventually duda manages to get some
coordination
creates some threats of his own black
has to now defend
and as we see magnus's only idea let's
go back to that point there
where he gets a check in magnus magnus's
only idea around this moment
is to try some desperation checks the
white king
moves up the board and here a very
practical choice this bishop is a little
bit dangerous there are some checks here
when
okay the white king can run away but
even if you have to give a bit of
material back
when you're lots of material up it's
often a good way to simplify
get rid of any nasty tactics and i like
this move
rook takes e4 the point of this is after
rook d4
the king is very safe on a3 and all of
these pieces protect
and they attack at the same time and
really now
get the hoover out it's a mop up job and
as we can see magnus
throws in a couple of checks but the
rook is clearly stronger than two pawns
that's something
we should all know the game goes on but
it ends
in a great victory for duda
and i have to say quite a you know quite
an important
moment in chess history because magnus
had this great streak
the longest ever streak of 125
wins but the duder stops it what can we
say about that well
you know he went for it magnus with the
black pieces and
it was bound to end his undefeated
streak so i don't think he should be
too disappointed i mean clearly if he is
worried about the streak
he wouldn't have played in this
dangerous manner but
also all praise to white the duda
keeps his cool he grabs the material he
defended perfectly
and he got a very important historical
win there
i'm sure magnus will bounce back but
we'll have to wait until
tomorrow to see how he's going to cope
with this loss he's not used to losing
after all
now do remember to like this video and
subscribe to the channel
and i'm sure i'll see you all again soon